susannah is with us in tampa florida hi
susannah how are you
um i guess i'm i'm not doing as great as
you are
you guys sound great um but i'm
a little bit embarrassed and also
distraught because
my question is not as wonderful as all
the other
questions everyone's very lucky
no it's okay what's going on how can we
help due to covid
and due to being laid off from my job 11
months ago
i've had to cash out my insurance policy
my life insurance
and my one and only son that i was
saving for
i do have an ira 67 000
and i do have my about maybe 2 000 in
cash
put aside i do have
one cd small one
a lot a lot of credit cards due to covet
but
my my question is um i'm having
difficulty getting another policy at my
age
obviously you can tell 65
and and it's mainly for my son but also
to pay off you know if i have anything
left over i don't know
how old is your son
he's 23. and why are you required to buy
his life insurance
no it's my life insurance that i wanted
to leave for him
no you don't need to do that see
i did it because and i won't say the
last name
i watched someone called susie which you
know who
um said you don't need life insurance to
keep paying
300 500 a month um
you should cash that out and put it in a
cd
or something well me and susie agree but
well i'm glad to hear that but i'm
having difficulty
finding a place to do that
yeah but the point is you don't need to
buy life insurance on a 23 year old and
you don't need to buy life insurance on
you to leave the 23 year old something
the 20 year old 23 year old needs to
make his way in his life and
and not leave his mother with this
burden right now
so mom you don't have that burden that's
easy now
and you don't even need life insurance
on you you've got enough to bury you if
something happens
and so you're good uh so now all we've
got to do is worry about getting your
career up and going because you're
starving to death because you haven't
been working
and credit cards which haven't slept
since last february
what were you doing what kind of work
were you doing
i believe it or not i was working at the
airport um
originally working with an airline got
laid off with that and then moved on to
pulling a check and boarding passes for
the passengers in front of tsa
and that's gone now too gone okay
so i'm doing uber when i can
okay and finding trying to find a way to
take credit cards off and not eat too
much yeah well
the reason you have credit card debt is
not covered the reason you have credit
card debt is coveted affected your
career
you lost your income now that is a
reason that people get into debt and
that's for real so
what we've got to do is hang on i'm
going to have uh kelly pick up and we're
going to get you on to ken coleman's
website let you download some things to
get you some ideas on some things to
start creating some income
and get some interviewing going because
what you have more than
anything honey is a career crisis
you have an income crisis that's right
so if we can get that fixed the rest of
this stuff is going to start to fix
itself and quit supporting the 23 year
old
period no circumstances is that okay
especially with all the things you're
facing you got enough irons in the fire
without him telling him to get it get on
with his life little pig